Hey youtubers it's Charlie. Yesterday during
my Korra trailer video I asked you all to
submit questions so I picked 10 to answer
in this video with one bonus question. Whenever
episodes start I'll be doing regular Q&As
after I do review videos for episodes.
It's just an easy way to follow up on something
if there's a couple of big questions that
aren't super clear the first time you watch
each episode. With that in mind, here's a
couple of clarifications about the characters
from the trailer. I'm not going to go crazy
with spoilers from the leaked episodes. But
if you want to comment on them, please use
the spoiler tag.
First off, this really is a young Lin Beifong
in Republic City. We don't know how old she
is exactly, only that it's in her early years
on the police force.
Second, this airbender is one of the new main
characters. She is from the Metal Bending
City but I won't say more just because she's
kind of important.
Third, this person is Lin Beifong's half sister.
We still don't know who either of their father's
were, but we can talk more about it in a future
bonus video. It means that Toph was either
married to two different people, or just had
relationships that didn't turn into marriages.
Fourth, this isn't Ba Sing Se. It's the misty
palms oasis. All those other scenes in the
trailer in the desert are probably tied to
this location. Ba Sing Se is in the trailer
too. But it's not this place. You also see
the oasis in this part where Asami is helping
Korra escape.
There was more information about this young
airbender, but because it's super spoilery
I'm going to wait till after I answer questions
to talk about him.
There have been some newer theories that because
the second issue of The Rift comic book is
coming out July 16th that Nick will start
airing episodes then. Comic Con is the week
after that, so they might wait till then though.
But tentatively plan on a mid to late July
premiere.
So here we go, I don't consider any of these
answers I give to be major spoilers. But fair
warning if you don't want to know anything
about Korra Book 3. Question 1 - Crystal asks
is Toph Still Alive, Missing, Dead?
One of the biggest unanswered Korra questions
ever. Nothing in the leaks or anything we've
heard has said alive or dead. The best info
we have is that at one point she pulled a
Zuko and just became a nomad, traveling across
the world and hasn't been heard from or seen
since.
Because that's what the producers said about
Zuko, I think that we'll see Toph eventually.
And because there are young Lin Beifong flashbacks
we'll see republic city middle aged Toph like
we did during Korra Book 1.
I wonder if beifong was a police officer when
all that Yakone stuff was happening...
Question 2 - Alice asks How many episodes
will there be this season?
There are 13 episodes just like Book 2. Whenever
Nickelodeon ordered more episodes of Korra
way way back it brought the total number of
episodes up to 52. That includes everything
from book 1, book 2, book 3 and book 4.
So that also implies that book 4 will be 13
episodes too, but I haven't seen confirmation.
Nick has been dead quiet about Korra news,
so it's unlikely that they'll order more episodes
after Book 4 is over.
If anything, they'd do a new spinoff or a
short Korra tv movie.
Question 3 - Bayard asks how are there so
many new Airbenders all of the sudden?
So there are a couple of answers to this.
First that there are repercussions from last
season relating to harmonic convergence. Like
bringing more balance to both the spirit realm
and the physical realm makes it easier for
people to tap into their own energy.
The other answer I'll call Sky Bison Logic.
Last season we saw a herd of sky bison being
bred in seclusion. It's possible that a group
of airbenders could have been living in seclusion
and everyone just didn't know about them until
book 3.
I've heard a few things from the leaked episodes
that kind of support this, but there's not
a lot of context right now. Other than people
are getting more power in combination with
airbenders always having been around, but
hidden somewhere.
Question 4 - actionvids asks who's Lin Beifong's
Father?
Still nothing about this. It seems like most
of Lin's story will focus on her relationship
with her surviving family members. There is
that half sister of hers, which makes me ask
all kinds of new questions about who Toph
hooked up with and why it didn't last, but
I am curious to see if we find out who the
father of the half sister is. Like if they
give us that information, but still withhold
the identity of Lin's father.
The only reason I think they'd choose to do
that would be if her father became a bigger
part of the plot in book 4.
I won't flip out if they still don't tell
us, but I think we'll have more information
about other members of her family. So it will
be a little easier to guess who mystery dad
is.
Question 5 - Rose asks Will Zuko be helping
team Korra or just the White Lotus?
I'm choosing to think of both plots as part
of the same thing. By the end of the season
both will come together anyway. So even if
Zuko is off doing his own thing in the first
couple of episodes. Eventually he will be
working with Korra.
After all the Zuko dragon riding clips I started
to get a lot of Avatar Roku flashbacks, so
I definitely think he'll give Korra some advice.
I'm really hoping he teaches her how to bend
blue fire.
Korra was so headstrong in season 1 it was
easy for her to firebend. But just like metalbending
it's super rare to see someone bend blue fire.
In Last Airbender they said only bending prodigies
could do it like Azula.
Question 6 - Count Swagula says I hope we
get to see Bolin evolve from just being comic
relief
Based on all the information that's been dumped
on the internet in the last week I think you'll
be pleasantly surprised with Bolin this season.
He'll always be a comedian, but I think because
we're spending a lot of time in the earth
nation he'll get a much deeper character arc.
It's not revealed in any of the leaked episodes
but I'm hoping he learns to Metalbend. Mako
learned Lightning Bending from the triple
triads, so it only makes sense Bolin would
eventually learn his sub bending style.
Question 7 - Milan Frances asks could you
explain what the political structure is, with
the President and the fire nation, earth kingdom,
air nomads and water tribe?
Think of it like Game of Thrones and the Seven
Kingdoms. In westeros when the andals invaded
they formed seven kingdoms. There were seven
different kings. Eventually Aegon Targaryen
conquered westeros and became the one king,
all the other kings became Lords.
So you know how the leader of the Fire Nation
is the Fire Lord. Originally before Avatar
Aang created republic city and formed the
republic the Fire Lord was a king. Now they're
just a Lord. So the term is much closer to
the truth. In case anyone wasn't sure, Zuko
passed the title of Fire Lord on to his Daughter,
the mother of General Iroh we saw in season
1.
Even though none of the different leaders
are King's or Queen's anymore, in the Fire
Nation and the Earth Kingdom it's still hereditary.
But the Water Tribe elects their leader and
the Air Nomads really don't have a leader
other than Tenzin. I think the nomads have
a much more loose political structure.
Question 8 - AzureRoxe asks is there any connection
between Combustion Girl and Azula, because
they look very similar?
Grey Delisle is voicing the evil water bender,
but I haven't seen any confirmation that she's
related to Azula. I'm not totally convinced
Azula will be in any episodes. It's like the
Sokka situation in Books 1 and 2. We got Katara.
But she never said where he was or if he died.
She barely referenced him at all.
So don't be surprised if Zuko does the same
thing. Just doesn't talk about his sister.
But I expect them to reference her at some
point. Even though we never saw sokka, we
did see that statue of him.
Not that I'm expecting an Azula statue.
Question 9 - Jack asks Is Korra still cut
off from her past lives?
Yes, and from the rumors I've heard it's going
to prevent Korra from entering the Avatar
State. Even during the leaked episodes supposedly
Korra doesn't enter the avatar state, even
during scenes when she would normally enter
the avatar state.
Like look at this giant sand shark. Don't
you think Korra would be in the avatar state
if this were happening.
It seems like one of the big running stories
in book 3 is going to be Korra discovering
how to enter the avatar state again. The producers
did an interview with the wall street journal
after Book 2 finished where they pretty much
implied Korra's past lives wouldn't be coming
back.
I think it will take all season for her to
figure out a workaround to that problem. So
if we don't see her entering the avatar state,
we know why. She did learn to energy bend
though. So that could be like a temporary
fix.
I'm hoping we get to see more energy bending
this year. I saw this crazy rumor that Avatar
Aang at some point used energy bending to
create a new airbender. Like he gave bending
to someone who wasn't a bender.
That's only something we've seen the lion
turtles do, but I guess it could be possible
for an avatar to replicate it. That's just
a rumor though.
Question 10 - Beric asks why did they show
so many fights in the trailer if the producers
said that Korra's biggest battle would have
nothing to do with her bending?
That's a really good question. The best answer
I can give you is that Mike and Brian had
nothing to do with making this trailer. Nickelodeon
probably did it as a result of that fake trailer
that was going around. Just for clarification,
when those episodes leaked, someone cut a
fan made trailer with a bunch of spoilery
stuff in it.
I think that Nickelodeon was more mad about
that then the mistake that led to MundoNick
posting the episodes early.
Mike and Brian have already talked about how
Korra's big challenge this season won't be
seeing who the better bender is, it will be
way more complicated than that.
The other possible reason for all the fight
scenes is that the person who cut the trailer
was just a random person at the studio who
has no idea what the narrative of book 3 is
supposed to be. So they just see a bunch of
action scenes and think fans will get excited.
And you end up with a fun looking trailer,
but one that ultimately tells a different
story than what Mike and Brian are telling
with the episodes.
It happens with movies all the time. The trailer
will just have all the big moments in it but
won't really tell you what the actual story
of the movie is.
Bonus Question - Andy (no avatar) asks what
is the sub bending element to air?
Supposedly it's what Jinora is doing here.
She's not in the spirit world, so she's not
necessarily in spirit form. I'd say the best
explanation is that
the sub style is astral projection.
Jinora is almost more spiritual than Korra
on the show, so it totally makes sense she'd
be the first person to learn a new sub style
of bending. When I started thinking about
it more I actually thought that she was using
the sub style during the book 2 finale.
Last year we were supposed to see the new
sub style but when no one said anything I
got confused. So I'm guessing they'll clarify
astral projection in the first couple of episodes.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions,
Book 3 is going to be awesome so I can't wait
to make more Korra videos. Like I said I'm
planning on just doing them every friday or
saturday. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
My next bonus video will probably be a breakdown
of who Lin Beifong's father might be. Also,
let me know if you want me to do weekly Korra
Q&As and I'll keep doing them too.
Right now click here to watch my breakdown
of the trailer and click here to learn about
the new Legend of Zelda they showed off at
E3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!